[Music]
what's going on guys welcome to shots of
odd now we're doing these extended
conversations these creative sessions
with some of the luminaries who have
inspired so many of these episodes and
you're about to see my conversation with
Eric Davis Eric Davis wrote Tech gnosis
which is a book that literally tickles
my brain it is a cognitively ecstatic
experience to read that man's words and
it's fascinating because his commentary
is about technology myth magic and
mysticism and the age of information
actually they put me in his head I feel
like I read his observations and I
relate to them and the thrill of feeling
like there's someone else in the world
who's thinking this way about these big
issues is astonishing so I hope you guys
enjoy this extended creative session
with the brilliant Eric Davis so Eric
Davis it's a thrill to be here with you
you have inspired me to no end I mean I
just gotta say first of all let me thank
you
thank you for your work for your ideas
for your book tech gnosis which is being
reissued and which has blown my mind to
no end
this book looks at technology in a very
different way than most people think of
technology I mean people people use
technology to extend their capacities in
the world to extend their communication
abilities but people also have an
apprehension about technology they're
afraid that the robots are taking over
you look at the kind of Gnostic
undertone so why don't you at first just
kind of tell me a little bit about where
Technic no no no that's it's a great
question I mean I I got interested in in
I got a sense of what was going to be
happening with technology in the in the
late 80s already I was studying
postmodern philosophy and reading
Gnosticism and science fiction and
philip k dick and then I became a like a
culture critic I wrote for the Village
Voice and I wrote a lot of record
reviews and things like that but I
noticed just sort of on the horizon that
there were these strange juxtapositions
of technology and religion technology
and mysticism and they were so peculiar
because we don't organize the world that
way oh there's religion and mysticism
and magic they're all there are old
stuff over there maybe in our dreams
maybe in our fantasies and then we have
the
the world we actually ration rationality
science progress you know leaving the
the shadows in the wake and I noticed
that that's actually not true and that
there's all sorts of ways in our stories
in our habits in in the images of the
way that technologies are packaged and
sold where we actually draw from the
religious imagination let's call them
whether it's from Christian ideas of
progress or occult ideas of magic spells
and powers or Gnostic dreams of
transcendence and kind of you know
moving onward and upward into the
heavens through our technology and so
what I wanted to do is sort of tell like
a secret history an esoteric history of
technology that paid attention that drew
all these shadows and figments and
stories out of the the background and
brought them forward so that people
could see really what was going on
already in a lot of ways that wasn't
percent and what could continuously
blows my mind you know and I experienced
a kind of biblio man see every time I
open this book it's this idea that any
page that I opened it to there's
something really relevant and really
just astonishing that you point out
about our relationship with technology
you know one of your chapters is called
the spiritual cyborg right that we are a
cyborg we are in a sort of coevolution
with our technology we extend our minds
into our tools and so on and so forth
but that there is this spiritual
yearning that we are beset with a thirst
for meaning and that continues you know
we may build the Hubble Space Telescope
put that in space mainline space and
time through the optic nerve
but because why because we're looking
for the holy other we're trying to blast
new tunnels between the mind and the
other it always comes back to the the
pressure of being a conscious being to
be sentient to face mortality to fancy
ourselves as gods but to be ultimately
food for worms and I just felt that you
just identified that thread throughout
and you did it so vividly and your power
with language with words I mean where do
you go when you when you when you write
this stuff and also like these
observations that you were making
probably reflect a journey that you were
take
yeah it comes from place if you wanting
to understand and you being beset with a
thirst for meanie yeah yeah tell me
about that well I like a lot of people I
I would say I was a spiritual seeker of
sorts and for me it was it was often a
very intellectual pursuit where I would
I wanted to know where these things were
coming from religions and mystery and
magic and the occult and meditation and
all that stuff but I was also a
practitioner I was searching I want you
know and and in some sense I still AM
yes um so I was fired up by that but at
the same time I I saw technology coming
I understood it really well it was like
you know my my father's a scientist I
was really tuned in to Science and
Mathematics studied mathematics and even
though I didn't end up studying science
I went I got seduced by the communities
right I've always had a real attraction
to it unlike a lot of people who work in
the humanities so I started to see that
all this stuff was coming in that it was
really gonna change everything it's
already changing everything is changing
finance it was changing you know our
self-image it was changing what we how
we think about ourselves and and so I
could see this kind of almost kind of
Apocalypse on the horizon you know and
it was the early 90s and you could tell
the end of the same end of the centuries
coming what's gonna happen there's this
sense of a kind of millennialism that I
was tuning into that that sort of
brought these worlds together so for me
it was really an attempt to kind of
integrate different sides of myself and
to continue to sort of tune into what
was happening in the future but to
recognize that these yearnings aren't
gonna go away right they just get
rephrased at a new point of view so
they're yeah so the spiritual cyborg is
basically the idea that you know a lot
of people who who are yearning for
spirituality or for a religious
connection they might think the
technology is taking us away from
everything you know that we need to
return to our roots return to nature
work we're too artificial
etc etc yeah I have a lot of
appreciation for that view but in a way
it's kind of obvious yeah and I wanted
to ask a deeper question which is what
happens when you actually embrace the
technological framework yes including
the idea that we are you know DNA meet
machines that are you know right you
know
spinning ourselves and the void and now
as we've extruded all of these
algorithms and technological processes
that have their life of their own that
we're now sort of riding the snares how
do we engage all that and embrace that
but still pay attention to be even be
driven by these deeper yearnings that go
much much farther back in our past and
so that's the kind of dialectic or
tension that I'm really trying to work
out in the in the book which is dazzling
and you know you talk a lot about the
emergence of the cyber culture in the
late 90s in the connection with the
Millennium and this idea that there was
this dream that these tools were going
to liberate us from the biological sort
of meat machine the biological
straightjacket and that we were going to
unleash our minds into a virtual world
as Terence Mckenna said about virtual
reality this will allow us to turn our
minds inside out that new forms of
intersubjectivity could be attained
because we would graduate from being
naked monkeys making little monkey
noises thinking they'd see God and
actually actualize a cosmos for the
imagination that we could inhabit you
know technology as McKenna used to say
is congealed imagination but now we can
actually move into and live inside of
our congealed imagination I mean we're
already kind of doing it and we talked
about architecture talking about
aircrafts but like even more so the
promise of virtual reality this was
there in that cyber culture in the 90s
and you know we're pointing to it but
then there's been this disenchantment
now do you think it's gonna come back I
mean now virtual reality is emerging now
I can rub the magic mirror on my iPhone
and some in a car that synchronizes with
my Spotify playlist to play the music
that I love so that my phenomenological
flow starts to feel like a rien chanted
world the Internet of Things predictive
contextual computing starts to create a
world of enchanted objects a world of
animism so all of us start to feel like
we're in a kind of an altered state of
consciousness where everything is in
sync with us and we start experiencing
engineered Serendipity's do you think
that that's possible or are you feeling
like oh it's a bunch of corporations
that are manipulating us well one of the
things that I'm that I talk about a tech
gnosis is that when there's when there's
new information technologies enter into
a culture when you have the Telegraph
when you have to tell
phone when you have television radio
when you when the technologies initially
enter into social reality and begin to
transform the way that we experience
ourselves communication and a
relationship to time and space when
those things happen there's a sort of
weird gap in the world where suddenly
there's a recognition that we're kind of
making this up as we go along and it's
not really clear what the new form is
right so into that gap rush fantasies
and dreams and revelations and terrors
and demons and fears and that that that
tension between the up and the down the
demon and the angel is sort of part of
the inheritance of technology so when
you ask that question you know what the
answer in a way is boring it's both and
look and that the the moment of
Revelation that were that we're kind of
moving into in that sense of oh my god
it's all coming you know things coming
together there's a kind of fantasy that
I'm living through the technology
there's a kind of synchronicity these
effects that are that are producing a
much more enchanted sense of moving
through ordinary life are intimately and
absolutely coupled with a kind of deep
suspicion and alienation and that those
are also features of technology they're
features of advanced capitalism and that
if anything they're closer they rub up
against each other even more than ever
before and so I don't you know I'm
neither an optimist or a pessimist in
the way that people like to align
themselves I'm much more interested in
trying to see how the dance between
these poles happens and then always
paying attention to I I have to own we
have to own our own projections too we
have to recognize what are we really
fearing what are we really trying to
transcend what do we really want how
much is our you know you talk about
Becker a lot how much is our fear of
death our secret constant unconscious
awareness that we are mortal creatures
motivating our trivial perceptions our
desires are our enjoyments and so for me
it's really about using
historical complexity conflict this
weird conjunction of beauty and awe and
terror and paranoia as a opportunity to
go even deeper into this ever-evolving
human condition in you know to keep that
edge Charlotte it's funny you mentioned
Becker and the idea of human mortality
but I mean ultimately technology is the
ultimate anti-entropic extension of
biology I mean Bucky fuller used to say
life is anti-entropic so entropy moves
towards destruction and simplification
of everything but then life moves
towards greater complexity and
organization upwellings of structure
self-organizing sublime complexity that
just seems to emerge and then we extend
thereby a lot by biology with the techno
sphere Kevin Kelley calls it the
Technium he says it's an organism the
seventh kingdom of life and so that this
move towards this anti-entropic move
towards more complexity of course is
connected to our desire to want to
overcome entropy itself to overcome
mortality itself I mean on the one hand
you can listen to a beautiful piece of
music while listening to your Bose
wireless headphones and the magical
music is streaming from your magical
smartphone which has 10,000 melodies
magically stored in its electronic
circuitry and you listen to it and that
gives you a real experience
there's nothing virtual about virtual
reality and it's a real virtuality as
jiseok says and I listen to that music
and I might get moved to tears and I'll
get the goose bumps and the chills and I
feel connected to something larger than
myself I technologically mediate ecstasy
and become as a God almost I enter god
mode to use a videogame right but then
you know the next day I have a headache
or I see a person who's older and is
suffering from an illness and I'm like
holy this is the existential bummer
right should we not use these tools to
transcend our mortal coil should we not
them the a that wants to molt himself
into angel rice you're lying yeah yeah
it might we must become machines we must
become gods you know man is a bridge
but not an end right what do you think
about that well I'm gonna approach it
promotes a slightly different angle
they'll get will get to that point yeah
which is I have a whole riff that I'm
pretty convinced about which is that
hedonism the pursuit of pleasure
including aw yeah and Wonder yeah
is it is a profound path in in most ways
of looking at it hedonism is seen as
sort of superficial materialistic it's
not religious it's not ethical it's not
higher and our society and ourselves are
very hedonic yes we are trained and we
learn to enjoy and we have great
pleasures that are at our fingertips if
we are lucky enough to be part of this
aspect of our world but I think what
people miss about hedonism what they
don't understand is that if you're
really asking is this really pleasurable
what is the whole package that comes
along with my pleasures yeah if you
start to become aware of the network of
effects where things come from where are
they leading what is the larger arena
within which I am enjoying okay then
suddenly things start to shift a little
bit because it becomes a little harder
for example to truly exalt in the god
power of your device right what do you
know about rare earth said you oh wait
those are oh there they're actually the
materials that we need in order to
shrink technology come with it almost as
some kind of alchemical allegory are
bound with highly radioactive material
that is very toxic and extremely
expensive to get so we're right where
we're in the we're still in the
alchemical wager it's a kind of alliance
with forces of the earth and forces of
destruction and fire as well as light
and transcendence and I'm not saying
that the recognizing this means that we
should pull back and you know and you
know destroy the machines and try to
return to some Paleolithic existence but
I do believe that you have to go further
and further into the complexities as
part of the pursuit of true enjoyment so
for me you start to ask a question of
what is transcendence what does it mean
to train
is it really transcendence to embed
myself in particularly technological
frames or perhaps there are other ways
of moving the mind other ways of
touching what is essential in us that
perhaps move at a different angle than
the sort of relentless pursuit of the
high because that comes with entailments
that comes with hidden packages you know
it's all it's all allies alliances pacts
deals balance always always interesting
to hear you say that because I think
that there's different flavors of
transcendence I think on the one hand
there's a feeling of eco Dalek
interconnection with everything where
you basically are extending your empathy
most people say empathy rarely extends
beyond our line of sight if it's out of
sight it's out of mind so an elevation
in consciousness means you start to be
aware of more interconnection more
consequences to your everyday experience
and so you extend your empathy and
that's a kind of transcendence and then
kind of communion with with everything
else but there's also other kinds of
transcendence there's just the mediation
and steering of awareness towards states
of exaltation in the sublime and that
can just be listening to rack man and
off on the piano and being moved to
tears while you stare into the iris of a
lovers eye which is something I've been
trying to do since I was in high school
okay like it's just that's why I love
cinema right because it's the last altar
left I get to go to that temple of the
IMAX theater which is the modern
equivalent of the Gothic cathedral it's
what allison griffith wrote about in the
book shivers down your spine that is as
a temple and a place where your
awareness can be mediated and pushed
towards places that tickle your soul you
know Iraq for the Soul and at the
soundscape and the massive screen can
can push you somewhere else can silence
the part of the brain that's responsible
for self-awareness you forget yourself
and that transcendence is pretty
blissful yeah they're all bliss junkies
in a way sure and I still think there's
validity in this oh absolutely
one of the another way of approaching
that is just asking this question which
is you know a lot there's been a lot of
you know neuroscience
study of the emotions yeah but it's
interesting go you know like with any
science you always go ok why they're
asking certain questions and they're not
asking other questions so what do what
do they look at they look at love
pair-bonding fear anxiety depression you
know these are the things that were tons
of research dollars like what's
happening in the brain right very very
little work has ever been done on wonder
and awe as if Wonder and awe are not
absolutely fundamental parts of our
nervous systems our humaneness as if
there's sort of some kind of weird fluff
that can be ignored as we get to the
real deal which is like these survival
tactics and part of the reason is
because Wonder and awe it's not so clear
what they're sort of selection by
viability is why do we have that it's
not clear exactly why that leads to you
know the perpetuation of the species the
way that fear and anxiety and even even
depression has it they have arguments
for there was a book and I did a video
about it called the biological advantage
of being awestruck where he says our
capacity to awe makes us work harder to
survive because of the bliss we get from
it yeah that's why I was biologically
selected for right it makes us be
impregnated with meaning because that
feeling to be connected with something
it's almost like like like the idea that
the brain is it has a god hack in it
yeah the reason that God hack was
pre-selected for us because it makes us
feel like we are holy beings yeah that
makes us fight harder to survive
particularly in terms of a group yeah
collectivity like we have a religion
clearly exists partly not just as a sort
of ideological control of mind control
kind of thing it's also a way of
orchestrating our effects and our
experiences and our sense of awe and
communion so that we collectively begin
to identify with shared myths shared
rituals that bring us into resonance and
allow us to survive and to prosper as a
collectivity I think one of the problems
that we have right now is you can just
see there's so much dissension there's
so much violence between you know
religion and people different
perspectives that in a way we're like
how do we how do we tap into that
potential for that potential for
passionate blissful connection with an
idea with with people with ritual but
somehow take it out of the parochial
quality and and the sort of tribal
quality it's like we both want we we
need some of the of the essence of
tribalism to return to within the in the
kind of breakdown in the journey the
breakdown of progress and yet that
tribalism also has within it a lot of
the most terrifying possibilities of
growth of fascism of a you know kind of
hatred and our like increasing people
share in that they buy over their hate
over some you know and so when I see
like like even the kind of conflict now
and with you know the Republicans and
the Democrats and it's just how how
nasty it's God how how sort of were see
every day it seems like like the the
rules are being broken down it's more
feral it's more out of control that
sense which I think is pervasive in our
society and it has that like real kind
of scary question of where does a
certain kind of tribalism I believe this
you guys are all crazy and I have the
websites to prove it
you know everything kind of feeds back
on itself and yet there's something in
that that connection that bond that's
very archaic that that we're working on
so how do we dissolve those boundaries I
mean McKenna used to talk about get on
an airplane five twelve hours and go
into another reality tunnel once you get
to have a visceral experience of how
other people live you tend to be a
little less judgmental you start to
realize there's not so many rights and
wrongs is just different yeah yeah but
my question that I wanted to ask you was
we're seeing a revolution now that's
connected to that idea of dissolving
boundaries with psychedelic research you
know McKenna used to say computers are
drugs and drugs are computers they're
basically computers for Innerspace you
know and we're seeing society kind of
have a turn around a change in the
attitudes I mean marijuana is probably
going to be made federally legal very
soon you know psilocybin studies for
people with terminal cancer been given
magic mushrooms and having reconfiguring
their whole perception of life and death
do you think that this is a step in the
right direction for potentially the
instantiation of a new kind of not
justice because you know like club
culture you know you go to a party in
Vegas
party Miami Beach and that is the
expression of party alcohol culture like
our drugs turn into our environments you
know our intoxicants are then reflected
in how we hang and where we hand what
the places we hang look like and feel
like as more people start to turn on as
the culture of these entheogenic
substances it becomes more accepted how
will that change the world yeah oh you
told me no no I mean I mean a lot of
things will be happening at once you
know I never never underestimate the
capacity for human beings to degrade the
sublime and so you know I and you could
take that even with looking at party
culture and how how MDMA or ecstasy
whatever is being sold as in BLC you
know and and those have had very
different expressions there's something
very utopian about the the rave scene
and there are aspects of it that are
really just an extension of that you
know alcohol crass party thing which is
fine it's just part of it's part of our
human baggage as well to not be
judgmental but it's also shows that that
you know Italy MDMA was seen as well
this is maybe a panacea maybe this is
this is the utopian pill that we need to
create bonding and connection and here's
a couples therapy and a pill you know
and you know of course the the the
results are a little more fragmented and
I think something like that will happen
with psychedelics as well on the other
hand you know obviously extremely
positive development one factor that
does seem to stay with people because
that's one of the questions like you can
have awesome experiences transcendent
sublime cosmic all the you know
beautiful adjectives in the world the
question of how it changes people over
time is much more murky it's not clear
that that if there's anything inherent
in any experience to change someone
permanently how true where true
transformation comes from is much more
of a difficult question you get a bliss
junkie people fall into addiction they
revert there's all sorts of things that
can happen but one thing that seems to
be a study show as a result of
psychedelic use is greater openness to
novelty that there seems to be a gene
you incensed that the nervous system the
mind whatever you want to say the soul
gets better at handling questions
ambiguities boundaries and others right
for me you mentioned the other at the
beginning of this conversation for me
increasingly as I think about these
things as I think about spiritualities I
think about ecology as I think about
psychedelics as I think about we know
what are we doing with all of our
devices it really comes into how are we
getting closer to the others and by the
others I mean the cosmos I mean animals
I mean microbes I mean circuits
I mean databases I mean this non-human a
human world that were absolutely
inextricably and meshed in that is in
some sense alive with its own you know
not just in the sense that the animals
are alive but although the whole system
has a has a spritely the matrix has
meaning you know matrix is aligned oh so
I want to talk to you a little bit about
that as well because now in order to bit
to be able to witness to make
observations about this aliveness to
sort of alter our experience of the
world enough that it becomes Rhian
chanted that we feel more connected to
it that we feel more compassionate to it
and that we're alive to the magic of
being we need to be playing with
subjectivity which is an obsession of
mine you've written about it you wrote
an essay called experience design and
the design of experience where you
describe experience as an evanescent
flux of sensation and perception that is
in a way all we have in all we are and
you say that new media technologies
cultural the cultural production of
media technologies needs to get better
and has to acknowledge that what it's
trying to do is engage the technical
material of subjectivity itself that our
cultural technologies are becoming more
like roller coasters than than like
movies and books that we are hacking the
body mind and being taken to new places
huh talk to me a little bit about
subjectivity and how we play with it
well is the term heterotopia to create
to describe the buzz that happens at
certain gatherings and conferences with
people that share certain values
come together and you start to enter
this other space with these people or
the space when you're talking to
somebody on the telephone across the
ocean like where is your mind in that
moment
tell me about heterotopia and playing
with subjectivity okay well I mean I'll
start talking about heterotopia that's a
term from Foucault and what he what he's
trying to point to is that you know we
have an idea of utopia of like some
perfect place where everything works out
yeah and he's like you know maybe good
luck
but heterotopia is a place where other
Ness is allowed to run riot so you know
an easy example with qualifications
would be something like Burning Man you
know where people go and particularly
early on when there was less cultural
ideas of how you were supposed to behave
and what it was meant and what clothing
was supposed to be and you be the furry
hats and all that you know it develops
its own heterotopia never lasts it's
always an evanescent point where people
come together and there's a kind of
open-ended question of like we don't
know what social interaction is going to
be we don't know what subjectivity is
going to be how our connections are
going to happen here and I think there's
a part of us that really seeks that
because we recognize in that the
possibility that things can be done
other than they are but the world is
doesn't have to be the way that it is
really because they transcend Michael
Pollan's been there isn't done that's of
the adult mind
yeah the existential boredom or despair
or belief that you've seen it all and
there's nothing else to be excited about
for a volte junkies right for people who
get a thrill from the idea of something
new of something more that seems to be
the antidote yeah anything that triggers
an experience that there could be
something else is addictive yeah and
that's it and that's a good point I mean
that once it becomes addicting if it
really is addicting then something more
complicated is entered than just the the
sort of generosity and richness of such
experiences because they become a little
bit more knotted uh and you've got that
so there that's part of the trap that's
part of the dialectic is for me what it
means is part of what that idea about
subjectivity and become
more aware of how our subjectivity is
produced is that even as we refine and
extend our pleasures our enjoyment our
capacity for intensity our capacity for
transcendence for connections with
others that there also has to be and
will be either by ourselves or by the
people who are producing those
experiences and increasingly let's say
third person understanding of how those
things come about what are the forces
that are the policy make the observation
right or the the technologists who's
tweaking the the device that you're
using to get off so to my mind expanded
consciousness is not just the exaltation
especially the exaltation produced from
technologies the expertise as to what it
takes to get exactly and it's in it so
it's a movement it's a movement where we
we move into intensity we take
everything we can from it we enjoy and
we draw from it and we feed it back into
a more critical understanding of what's
leading to this what's actually behind
it what actually does it what are the
entailments what are the connections and
that's where you start to get involved
with a more critical sense of like who's
actually making money from this what are
they doing with my data what are they
doing with my and so I you know think
that both sides of that is what it means
to become more and more intimate with
subjectivity so we've been talking about
subjectivity right the nature of lived
experience now I'm a fan of ecstatic
states I'm a fan of flow states when you
feel your best and you perform your best
it's wonderful oh yeah Steven Kotler and
Jamie we love the flow Genome Project
talk about advances in technology
psychopharmacology neurobiology and
psychology the four pillars that are
allowing us to peer beneath the hood of
what's going on in our brain during
these ethereal mysterious numinous mind
states but I guess I want to talk to you
about the subjective experience of
subjective States that we love you once
gave a talk where he talked about dream
walking you know you go through a
certain
urban settings and you're able to
catalyze the mood where you're able to
to actually be be receptive to the fact
that architecture objects streets
buildings cathedrals architecture talks
to you right like when you design
something it has shape as a form factor
I mean there's there's agency and
intention and a language to the forms
and figures that we make you know when
you walk around Prague or Berlin or
Amsterdam New York if you're in the
right receptive subjective States the
world of objects talks to you there's a
kind of animism right how do we turn on
our openness to that animism versus the
normal operating baseline consciousness
which is in task oriented and I gotta
get from here to there yeah and I'm not
stopping and staring up at the cathedral
for 15 minutes marveling at the forms of
the concrete the mindedness in the and
main world no you're asking you get
there how do people get there you know
it's you're asking a really key question
it's not easy because you know we you
know the world the empire of work is
also everywhere we go I mean that's part
of what it means to always be online and
always in every use right and in my
experience the my answers my practices
tend to not be particularly
technologized you know like while I
appreciate the kinds of things that
cinema can deliver that virtual reality
endeavor the games can deliver that you
know there's a lot of ways in which that
even pharmacology even even raves or
whatever that my answer to your
questions are much more are kind of more
simple and embodied and they really have
a lot to do with the body
okay and not just states of mind but
really this body that there's a way of
walking there's a way of holding and
those are the things that for in some
ways are personal with me that I've
discovered in my body because of the way
it's constructed over a long period of
time but I think that there's a way of
learning the subtle edges of
consciousness which are almost
imperceptible if unless you're kind of
really looking for them or have a good
structure to see what they are that a
lot of very ordinary states conceal
right inside of them
fabulous opportunities that the the mind
that takes a the daydreaming mind the
mind that takes a nap the mind that
spaces out that sort of stop staring at
the field in front and kind of opens the
ears to take in the totality of the
sound yeah if you start to develop these
kind of simple what's the kind of its
kind of like meditation but it's more
like meditation on perception on on the
discotheques yep playing with perception
that that can actually provide over time
you know it's like like meditation like
a lot of these things it's not instant
right remarkably more enchanted world I
have to ask you know most people if they
want to unwind they'll have a glass of
wine you know they'll have a glass of
champagne they'll have a vodka it does
something specific to your subjective
experience it loosens your inhibitions
it might make him more horny there is a
specific use for that intoxicating the
majority of Americans now support
marijuana legalization obviously for
medicinal purposes but also like in the
Michael Pollan article and a psychedelic
Renaissance the idea of making well
people better David Lentz in' in his
book on drugs
he's a comparative literature professor
wrote a chapter on cannabis in marijuana
that blew my mind he says that
essentially marijuana fuses cognition
and dream and creates a reconcilable
estrangement with the world of
perception without really distorting it
now the reconcilable estrangement means
at first the world of the ordinary
becomes a little strange and a little
extraordinary but then you get to
re-engage with it because of its
strangeness and novelty and reconcile
your relationship with the world of
perception and object so somebody might
get high and listen to a song that
they've always loved but all of a sudden
they remember why they've always loved
it it's soul searing intensity pierced
directly into their brain or why the
effect or the intellectual might smoke a
joint before going to the Guggenheim
Museum or the Amsterdam Museum of the
moving image so as America's attitudes
about cannabis as medicinal and
recreational substance sort of comes
online how do you
we will be able to start playing with
this fusion of cognition and dream to
make ourselves more perceptive to
aesthetic experience because ultimately
that's what it's about you go you want
the home theater surround sound external
technology but maybe with the
legalization of cannabis now you can
have the internal technology that
Prime's your brain to be more open to
that mediation yeah yeah for me although
the surround sound structure is too much
it's too invasive and it kind of
flattens that the the space of
interaction and encounter that is that I
find on cannabis or not on cannabis
walking in the woods with it before a
great work of art ok listening to a
symphony listening to you know even a
punk show or whatever that there's a
sort of space there that our technology
as its getting good at manipulating our
consciousness really wants to move in
there and really trigger fast and really
dial down and really get us sort of like
on line with it and some people are
exalting about that opportunity and I
don't have a judgement about that I act
I'm glad that there are Lab Rats I'm
glad that there are post humans who just
who are plunging far forward into that
as they can that's not my welcome and so
for me when you talk about this sort of
these opportunities it's it's a little
bit more about how to bring the edge of
dream into reality and so the way you're
talking about how cannabis sort of opens
up the the sort of first layers of dream
Association both weirdness and greater
intimacy right and I think it's really
interesting to imagine that a lot of
people who maybe are turning to cannabis
for medical reasons because they've
always heard about it now it doesn't
seem so bad the people who are able to
to have that encounter maybe they've
never been interested in the
counterculture and drug culture or
anything that because of that aesthetic
sensibility in particular I think that
there's a really great opportunity for
people to whatever you know join a gym
or whatever and get out of the the ruts
yeah and sort of Leary's ubiquitous idea
of set and setting getting fed back into
the experience
you're changing the culture in which
people can enjoy these intoxicants
responsibly by changing the cultural
context in which they're enjoying it
you're changing the effect that they're
gonna have because they're not gonna
feel scared they're not gonna feel like
deviants instead they're gonna feel like
they're having a drink except a slightly
different effect and then re-engage with
the world through the lens of that prism
it could be interesting to see how it
affects conscious yes absolutely so
something else I'd like to bring up to
you we've talked about subjectivity
we've talked about altering our
perception with external mediation and
Technology with internal technology
we've talked about our hunger that that
for for something more for a hidden door
to connect with something transcendent
to connect with something infinite to
deal with our mortal oil you know a film
that resonated with an entire generation
I think continues to resonate is the
matrix so here you have a film that was
a pop culture phenomenon but it was a
profound philosophical meditation on the
nature of reality
on the desire for transcendence and for
escape and you probably wrote I
confidently believe the most magnificent
piece on the matrix ever written
it's called synthetic meditations and I
want to read you a quote by you and have
you comment on it because when I first
saw the film it unsettled me and excited
me kind of like certain sexual
situations but forget for a cognition
like it just mentally made me
uncomfortable but also secretly really
excited about what this means right and
and the move the scene in which neo
takes the pill for those who've seen the
film and then starts melting into the
mirror you describe that scene better
than anybody so I want to read it okay
so first Morpheus tells neo no one can
be told what the matrix is you have to
see it for yourself
and then Eric Davis sums up the scene so
like the serpent in the Garden of Eden
Morpheus offers neo a pill neo of course
swallows the molecular package which is
really the most heroic act in the film
for neo must then face his own Cartesian
passage through madness melting into a
mirror that eludes not only to Lewis
Carroll Alice in Wonderland but to the
mystic psychotic collapse and
disappearance of the externalized ego
that stabilizes our inner void as neo
phases out of the matrix he opens up
however briefly the fractured Bardo okay
that is the secret thrill of every fan
of the false reality genre myself
included the moment when baseline
reality dissolves but no new world has
yet emerged in its pixelating wait so
it's neo starts melting into the mirror
and he's freaking out it's when Dorothy
gets caught up in the tornado and ends
up in Oz it's when we leave our
cognitive Kansas behind it's the dream
within a dream sequence and inception
it's Willy Wonka's chocolate factory I
mean it's all of these stories the
kiddie psychedelia and the modern
Gnostic pop culture but why do we get so
excited from being unsettled about the
nature of reality isn't that supposed to
be just scary how come we like it yeah
that's a great question I mean IIIi
asked myself that question because I
think like you I have to answer that
more as much personally as sort of
objectively I can sort of talk like an
historian and say well could the jalmer
develops here and serving these days
blah blah blah but that doesn't answer
why I get the thrill out of it and why I
have since I was a kid whether philip k
dick or agent Lovecraft or whatever and
then not you know and even when I study
religion and I'm really interested in
Gnosticism and the history of
esotericism it's often from a similar
point of like if I keep following this
line it might just start to turn around
a corner swear now I actually can't rely
entirely on my given map of reality I
mean I think that's a very healthy
impulse to question the sort of
framework and I think that experiencing
it as a thrill is kind of is a truthful
reflection
the way in which we are forced to kind
of that it's always something that
happens to us it's not just an idea it's
not just like oh there's another world
behind this world it's an experience of
loss which in a sense is a little
premonition the big loss
leaving the everyday right and it's a
kind of death you know it's a kind of
mean that's that that's the point is
that is that neo has to die not only to
the world but to the person he thought
he was - the relationships that
sustained him the identity that sustains
him the job that he has all of that
which is a kind of death yeah and so the
idea that there is something more is
pleasurable but also the sense that
there is something in us that can
navigate such transitions and I think
that's part of Ives there is a witness
that can move through world right and
dance with it and yet move it and I
think part of the this also that the
sort of secret encoded in the in the
matrix is precisely that that this is
also a film in which the the special
effects that were most novel in that
film which then of course become
ordinary in subsequent iterations has so
much to do with the kind of ballet of
movement the kind of you know the the
the the manipulation of time moving
through different speeds and slowness
--is yeah all of those to me were an
indication of the way in which the films
were encoding not just the false reality
genre but also a kind of almost almost a
sort of shamanic encouragement that you
actually have the capacity to navigate
this degree of uncertainty this degree
of not knowing what's a fiction and
what's a fact and that's of course one
of the main things that we face that
we're already in this world and that is
going to become more intense is that
that division between fiction and and
fact that the hard reality of where our
bodies die and the and you know the the
water tables are collapsing and and you
know people are manipulating the the
you know whatever the economic system
for really untoward gain that's going
along at the same time as which there's
this profusion of fictions in fact it's
really hard to get at reality you know
if I want to well if I'm like she would
you know what happened with the Boston
bombing it was kind of weird like I oh
you know I want to find out what really
happened that day
yeah where am I gonna go in which
conspiracy theory and then they're all
conspiracy theories and then it's all
loose all of a sudden and I'm in my own
private Idaho's flying blind trying to
communicate trying to coordinate some
consensus sense of reality and you get
into like the Roswell stuff UFOs and and
I'm saying that not to say oh we should
be conspiracy theorists or oh we
shouldn't be conspiracy theorists
because I wouldn't say that either by
any means but it's more that that dance
with fictions which is in a way the
dance of the matrix is part of our
existence now is part of our politics
it's part of our self-identity it's a
part of thing it's part of what we're
doing everything everything is kind of
theater and there's there's some
scariest to that there's some nihilism
to that there's a there's a deep
alienation in putting that and at the
same time there is an invitation to a
better kind of play or a bit a better
kind of performance yeah well even even
just cognitively intellectually and
aesthetically for me I think it provides
a safe place in which I can go to
dangerous places and ask dangerous
questions with my mind I mean I think
that neo taking the pill and then me
wondering what's it gonna do and then he
turns right and his arm starts to melt
that the freaky almost like
schizophrenic disjointed of everyday
reality is the cognitive equivalent of
when you're going up on the roller
coaster
before it's about to flip over the top
and drop insane and you can't really
even see the bottom because it's going
up but it's about and that feeling you
get in your stomach the cognitive
intellectual equivalent of that is that
or the dream within the dream scenes in
Inception where he explains that when
him and his wife went into the limbo the
fourth layer then they decided to hide
their little artifact and then she
forgot that she was in a dream so that
after living a whole life there and him
saying this was all in well it's
make up then she brought the belief that
that dream wasn't real into their real
waking state and that's like a person
having a psychotic breakdown is a person
that can become convinced that this
reality is not real because I mean if
you're fully convinced that's it you're
not tied into the consensus train right
you're either in your own personal
heaven or your own personal hell yeah
and I think that flirting with that in
these kinds of films gets certain people
off right yeah portal Sunshine of the
spotless mind another example yeah and
that's also very old if you go back in
the history of religion particularly in
India you know that that there's all
there's very ancient tales of dreams
within dreams within dreams with people
living entire lives and then realizing
that it was all just a fantasy
so that idea is very fundamentally part
of human consciousness and I think it
has to do with our experience of dream
yeah in the sense that this is not a
cultural construction this is something
all human beings dream and all human
beings have been dreaming for tens if
not hundreds of thousands of years and
one of what one of the conclusions from
dream is that I can be very much in a
real world and then not anymore and that
gap is a kind of gap of freedom but we
in a way we can only get into that gap
of freedom by also risking either
psychosis or death right now and that
that's part of the thrill because we're
just getting a little flavor at it if
movie is safe I'm in a cushy seat on my
popcorn right and yet there is a kind of
cognitive memory and anticipation of
other kinds of gaps that maybe are much
more difficult right
right and that's partly then how we
navigate a culture that is changing so
fast that is so full of fabricated
realities and that is so full of
glitches and noise that's why for me
it's always really important to pay
attention to not as well as using a
technology to get what you want or to
enjoy what you're going to enjoy and
even recognizing how it is a kind of
congealed dream of a possibility of a is
that at the same time it's also kind of
a pain in the ass you know it's good it
brings along things that I didn't intend
it doesn't work the way I want to and if
I look into the the conditions under
which it was made and how it's being
sold and how its entering into people's
lives then I see all sorts of glitches
and all sorts of cracks all sorts of
little abysus that open up and for me
it's like we're in a process now where
both of those mines have to be operative
so I think that there's something very
powerful as well as juicy about these
gaps these glitches these cracks because
that is where our our critique lies our
that is where our our willingness to not
by the comforting dream lies and so we
learn to play with self-correct yeah
well it reminds me a little bit of that
danny boyle film the beach when they
sort of find that island and they go to
this paradise and then the whole idea is
nobody wants to bust up the party so
when one of the characters gets sick or
one of them gets bitten by a shark they
just put them in the woods and throw
them away so it's out of sight out of
mind because nobody wants a buzz killing
nobody wants to hide to go away yeah I
think what you're saying and you're
saying so well is that even as these
tools and technologies the myth magic
and mysticism that's giving us so many
wonderful experiences that we should
still be mindful of what it took to get
there and what are the consequences that
it's causing so that we can remedy
self-correct adjust upgrade and make
sure that we are living to our sort of
potential as you know people in believe
justice and a sense of right absolutely
we're not just bliss junkies at the
expense of but rather that we can sort
of bring everybody into this waking
dream as we author it excellent well
said
dude this has been an absolute treat
just a cognitive thrill you've taken me
on the best kind of roller coaster Alice
in Wonderland I've transcended my
cognitive kansas and everything I like
so thank you thank you for what you've
produced thank you for existing thank
you for tech gnosis which has been
reprinted and I think everybody should
read as part of their their journey yeah
people still like it I mean it's it was
written a while ago and yet it still
resonates you notice clearly clearly and
inspires in some way that I'm not
entirely in control of it and I'm very
happy with you belongs not to you well
well
right but um whatever it is you
channeled into man I just want to I just
really want to thank you because I'm
I've been like I've this is the kind of
book that I'd like to take with me and
like to open to any page and like to
read something fascinating that usually
triggers a shot of I episode and and all
kinds of cognitive thrills so make sure
you pick up tech notices make sure you
follow Erik Davis on Twitter he's act
Eric underscore Davis Eric with a K at
the end at Eric underscore Davis get
tech gnosis today and your podcast why
don't you tell everybody about your
podcast or what's called expanding mind
it's on the progressive radio network
and it's been going for about five years
and recover consciousness neuroscience
spirituality technology sort of zones
that are covered in this book as a
weekly CH chat very similar to this sort
is informal but petty and have a
wonderful co-host Mazda oh the White
Witch of LA so I got to give a shout out
to do hamaji and that we have a lot of
fun yeah so check out expanding minds
and thanks for watching shots of awe
creative session in conversation with
the dazzling Eric Davis I love it
your theater guys was great any real
problems I can't help it it could be but
you know for me the best part of a trip
is always waking up in the morning I
mean coming down is the good part you
know it should be anyway coming down is
the part where you're like okay you what
about that what yeah what did I learn
and how do I apply this and what is this
and then you know and then you go out in
the woods and you you smell reality
again from that new from that new place
and you realize oh my god I've only tip
I'm only one percent of what I could be
[Music]